we at mozilla realized this and we we
saw
javascript was something that you could
compile to use adobe had somebody in the
adobe labs doing this too he had a
project called alchemy
we had somebody who's now google um
alone zakai who did his own
llvms compiler that would take c or c
plus plus and it would emit javascript
and you would think this is crazy
you're going from this sort of machine
types low level
you know controlled memory allocation
language to this garbage collected
dynamically typed uh high level higher
level language
but alone sort of just
phenomenologically carved
nature the joint found the forms that
were fast in javascript
and then with dave herman who i'd
recruited from north eastern university
who
was a type theorist and um luke wagner
was still at mozilla
who was the compiler guy and and the jet
guy
they figured out how to codify what i
wanted
done into a typed subset of javascript
called
asm.js and this is a strange thing to
think about because it doesn't have new
syntax
the types are casts that
occur in dominator positions in the
control flow graph
so it's like a hack on javascript and
it's a subset and it uses
those bitwise operators that i talked
about copying from java
to basically cast
numeric types which are double precision
floating point into integers
and so inside javascript in the kernel
semantics
are integers and if you use these
operators if a compiler emits them in
the right places
you can then treat them as typed values
typed memory
locations and you can type check your
program
you can not only type check it you can
compile it this is all in sort of linear
time oh and
you can compile it to have deterministic
performance it doesn't touch the garbage
collector
it calls a bunch of functions that come
from the c functions or c plus plus code
that you're compiling
and you can make the epic unreal engine
go in 30 frames a second yeah and when
we did this in 2013 in the fall
you know tim sweeney i met um didn't
think it could be done quickly i thought
it would take years
and the team went to raleigh to epic and
in four days they had unreal engine
ported by
pressing a compile button right they had
but they had to have webgl
which came from opengl es came to opengl
which came from silk and graphics gl
they had to have web audio so they could
map open al
which was another audio library standard
to web audio which was kind of a chrome
idiosyncratic thing
um but they they could make it work and
they had to have
asm.js for fast c plus to javascript and
uh if you didn't have that fast compiler
step
the javascript you'd write by hand
trying to do an unreal game would be too
big and too slow it would touch the
garbage collector it would not
keep up with 30 frames a second on the
hardware 2013 hardware
so we demoed that at um this has been
fall 2012 now i think about it because
we demoed it at
gdc game developer conference 2013 and
people were stunned it's like
unreal engine unreal tournament running
in my browser window no plugin
no flash no java no so where does the
early days of
because javascript now is able to run
basically on par
with a lot of the like c plus plus yeah
and even before then you had the fast
javascript vms in 2008
when chrome came out just before it came
out mozilla
my friend andreas gal and i uh and
others hacked out trace monkey our
trace-based jet the squirrel fish
extreme
team at apple did their jit and we were
all competing on these
crazy performance benchmarks it was a
little bit too much tuning in the
benchmark but
javascript started getting fast and
developers started noticing it but it
was still kind of this
its own high level language with garbage
collection the asm.js
step helped us go further because until
we really
proved the concept people were still
saying well javascript's okay it's
getting faster thanks to v8 everybody
gave google credit especially google
but we need something to kill flash
let's use the portable native client
code that google had acquired native
client
um which is a separate lineage for
taking basically c
code compiling it into a software fault
isolated container of some sort
using some kind of virtualization
technique and
maybe it can even be in process and
still be memory saved that would be
awesome but they ended up using process
isolation too and that kind of
weakened it and in the end it was like
portable native client okay
you know meet new boss same as zeal boss
this is the google flash right
yeah but but when we did asm.js and we
showed unreal engine working
i think it was only a matter of time
before google threw in the towel and in
fact
everybody agreed in spring of 2015 we're
going to take
what was proven by asm.js and make a new
syntax a binary syntax that's efficient
that loads into the same javascript vm
that javascript loads into so there'll
be two source languages one vm
very important one garbage collector one
memory manager one
set of compiler stages and that's called
webassembly
and that's the successor to asm.js and
it's important to
have binary syntax because at the end of
the day especially on mobile if you're
downloading javascript even if you're
using lz compression on the wire that's
cool but you've got to blow it out into
memory and then parse the silly
eight character function keyword that i
picked
when i could have used something shorter
i picked it because of awk the
unix tool um so anyways i'm not
following i want to but i'm not
following
the awk thread yeah is it surprising to
you
that uh how damn fast javascript is
these days i mean like cause you've been
through the whole journey yeah i know
every
every step of the way but is it like i
mean it's
it feels incredible it does but i knew
so the funny thing is computer science
is this big
karmic wheel right wheel of fortuna um
and uh in the most in 97
i was loaned by netscape to do due
diligence for
sun in their acquisition of anamorphic
which was
uh david unger uh come and and friends
um people uh craig i'm forgetting his
name he went to microsoft
uh these stanford language buffs who'd
taken small talk and then david
created itself as a simpler sort of
small talk language
and made really fast just in time
compiling
vms for them and they you know well
ahead of
java hotspot or javascript v8 or any of
these modern vms
figured out how to make dynamic code
fast because small talk is
a dynamic language right it has classes
that has i think more lockdown
declarative syntax than javascript but
it's fundamentally dynamic you don't
declare the types
um but you could in further types as the
program runs and you start to form these
ideas about what types are actually
flowing through key operations and you
form little
so-called polymorphic inline caches that
are optimized machine code
the cache is the machine code that
assumes it does a quick check to make
sure the type is right and if it's not
right it bails to the interpreter
and if it is right you go pretty fast
and that short
test is a predicted branch so things are
things are pretty quick
all that amazing stuff i knew about the
90s and i
i didn't have time to do it and
anamorphic got bought by
sun and they did hotspot and you needed
that even in java because
at scale java has some dynamic aspects
due to invoke
interface you can have basically
collections of java code where
you don't know at the time each each
module or package is compiled
exactly what's being called what what
subclass or what
implementation of an interface is being
called and so you want to optimize using
this sort of dynamic polymorphic caching
there too
and they did that hotspot it's amazing
amazing beast i've met like 13 people
who all claim they created it
i think i think one of them may deserve
credit more than others um
but uh i didn't get to do that in
javascript
and when we knew that that google uh was
going to do their own browser which we
knew at mozilla around 2006
i also met the team that did v8 and it
turns out it was lars bach who was one
of the young engineers from anamorphic
got acquired by son and so lars is like
the one of the world's expert on these
kinds of virtual machines
and he picked my brains about javascript
i could tell he didn't like it at the
time but
he had to do it and oh really
interesting yeah in 2006 lunch at
google's campus um and and
then i had another friend who was
deverell at chrome and he said yeah we
don't know what they're doing this is
getting 2007
to fall getting toward 2008 we're trying
to get chrome out and we don't know
what's going with the v8 team they're
often all hosts
denmark you know rewriting their engine
four times which is good that's the
right way to do this kind of development
you know they were learning javascript
including all its quirks which they came
to hate
with the fire of a thousand suns which
is one of the reasons that lars and
company did dart
their own language but they also made
the language fast and
meanwhile we knew this was happening so
we got our act together with um
trace monkey are tracing jet at mozilla
and apple i think was also aware and so
they were doing their own
so the era of jitted fast javascript in
2008
had this pre-history going back to small
talk itself
and anamorphic and the again the lineage
is interesting because you have lars and
anamorphic and then he ends up with
google
yeah and today we have an incredibly
fast
language that like you said still
you know without hate you can't have
love so uh i
i think there's both love and hate for
this dance
uh this rich complex dance of javascript
throughout his history there's a
dialectic of sure for sure
you